the longer people watch the more likely
they are to keep watching you don't need
to try as hard in the back half of the
video as you do in the front get people
where they're really immersed and hold
them there yeah I agree with this I love
this because
um and we teach the perfect video recipe
which would be the big idea to hook the
content and the transition the hook is
just spending time to architect the
beginning of the video and if part of
that even if you were just to say do a
live stream and you were to do a video
podcast we thought about the hook up
front to try to pitch the value and say
why that you know listen to the end
there's going to be a lot of tactics to
be a very nuanced conversation and so we
are really freestyling our responses
based on our experience here but we
architected The Hook Once people get to
the back half they're probably committed
especially in this setting you know
there's people in our think media
podcast Community walking their dog
right now they're at the gym right now
you you don't really set down the
weights you're like committed to
listening to the this longer form
conversation so this is completely true
I think that selling people not just on
the opening of the video but the topic
itself the topic title thumbnail that's
the big idea The Hook Once someone is
invested absolutely they'll probably
stick around so it's it's a poignant
sentence and a couple of sentences that
we could all learn from